Goldman can do certain things,
um,
can not issue certain rules,
can regulate septum markets,
can allowed,
uh,
interesting companies to be fear or less
fear to move on,
uh,
can be taxed them.
Oh,
can text more than,
of course.
What is more important for the Italian
economy is to regain trust and itself.
And they ain't company yesterday games
pricing themselves and,
uh,
to keep going with the speed of
innovation and a,
that they had for so many years from the
fifties,
sixties,
seventies,
eighties,
there was a crisis,
a of chorusy name all Europe as we know.
I mean,
it's,
uh,
the productivity,
it doesn't grow as much as we would like
a day output.
Industrial output doesn't grow as much
as we would like.
They in turn a little man is kind of
soft.
Uh,
but you know,
it keeps innovation in terms of moving
things and they helped a tie and
company.
Diane comedy can,
anytime in economies loughridge can find
again,
that spirit of innovation that was
collect three stick that,
uh,
the carthay through all the economy end
up dying and companies for so many
years.